we gotta we got to talk about this this
this fight this weekend there's a very
cool fight and we have a friend of the
podcast fighting this weekend mar usman
is fighting this weekend
against uh a british man named leon
edwards
and
they fought once before usman beat him
yeah this is before usman became
in some people's eyes the pound super
saiyan
super saiyan goat you know me right now
it's always going to be izzy
but you know mad love to camaro and he's
looking [ __ ] unstoppable yeah
so
who do we have this week i think camaro
does it i think he gets tomorrow does it
i also i want to see the betting lines
because i want to use my schulte
stimulus
but i also wonder just as a different
conversation what's let's say he beats
the [ __ ] out of this guy yeah let's say
it's easy what does he do next what's
what can he do so he had this
interesting thing about going up two
weight divisions yeah because where he
is right now he's at i believe
welterweight okay so izzy's at 185 so
he's at 170
is he's at 185 and then after that is
205. so he doesn't want to fight izzy
because they're homies so he's like i
want to go up two weight divisions
that's [ __ ] and then fight it 205
jesus that would be wild that'd be
insane that would be absolutely insane
did you fight at that uh
so the champ at 205 right now is yuri
pro hotskam probably pronounced his name
wrong he had that crazy fight with
glover to share that was [ __ ] a war
it was insane glover to share a beat jan
blehovic yamblochovic beat izzy when
izzy went up and wait yeah so it will be
that same kind of belt now please
believe if oozman goes all the way up
fights and wins
people are gonna be clamoring for a
fight with izzy
because that could make him a three
division champion oh [ __ ] and you figure
well if you can win a belt two divisions
ahead of you yeah what's gonna stop you
from winning it one division but also
people might give him that already
because if you beat the guy
that's interesting yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's interesting but yeah i don't
know i don't know i don't see anybody
being izzy right now izzy's got the
crazy fight that's going to be in new
york i can't wait for that [ __ ] man i
just booked shows that [ __ ] weekend
no in wisconsin before izzy announced
and i was like i wanted to
cancel but good yeah i specifically was
like we need to do comedy on state
before the end of the year yeah found
that open week and took it and then izzy
i think that's thanksgiving weekend
though no i think it's like november
10th or something 10th 11th the easy
fight oh it is okay i mean that is just
i mean that's going to be [ __ ] crazy
and i think you i think izzy takes him
out and i think it's kind of easy yeah
the thing with izzy i think we've
realized and like ariel helwani had put
it just put this great one when i was on
his pod
he's like none of these guys people like
oh these these fights with izzy are
boring it's like
none of these guys are trying to take
the belt away yeah they're just trying
to survive out there that's how you
become champ right you know i mean so
they're putting all the onus on izzy to
make the fight interesting it's like
well what about the guy that's
challenging yeah he's defending
he's defense he is the champ already
come get it bro this is what they were
saying about mayweather
the same thing come get it you have to
beat him he don't kind of beat you he
really he's already the champ and izzy's
been to war he's done fire seen him do
it with gastelum yeah i'm prepared to
die yeah so i i'm [ __ ] i'm hyped for
that because this guy
one he's the guy who knocked out izzy
but if you watch the whole fight izzy's
[ __ ] him up the guy they should have
stopped the fight izzy's like got him up
on the ropes the ref just let him go in
and then he caught izzy with that
[ __ ] left hook and the guy got
[ __ ] crazy pop but
what i'm excited about is now people
think there is a threat to izzy before
there was nobody yeah they were just
inventing threats like i'll be this guy
or that guy who's gonna have to repeat
fighters he's always [ __ ] demolished
right now there's someone who like oh no
this guy could make it happen this guy
could be izzy so now we're interested
we're excited it's in the [ __ ] mecca
right the garden but also
we have somebody who i think only knows
how to go forward
we're going to see if he's able to do it
once he starts getting touched up by is
he you know what i mean and back when he
fought is he there with boxing gloves
yeah look we're going to see how it
feels when you're up on the ropes
getting pounded on with these little
tiny mittens
gloves will probably be like eight
ounces and the lowest and these are four
ounces okay so it hurts more
okay interesting
but way less the rest of the card this
weekend is amazing it's camaro leon
edwards yep paulo costa luke rockhold no
that fight's going to be crazy that's to
be sick acosta or luke rockhold both go
in there bang i mean luke's been getting
knocked out a lot lately a lot of people
say he's getting a little bit chinny
which means like it's easy for him to
get knocked out yeah but uh which does
happen i guess you're once you get your
lights turned out a few times it's just
like your ability to turn the punishment
every your chin gets shorter every time
you get knocked out shorter of what it
gets easier to knock you out yeah yeah
100 100 and then jose aldo
is
yeah yeah it's i don't know too much
about the guy that jose is fighting but
jose is just a [ __ ] legend he seems
like the favorite in the money line i
mean it's hard to you know it's hard to
bet against jose he's just no i'm sorry
marab
yeah he's i guess the up-and-comer yeah
all right yeah i think we should all
take a bet this weekend i i don't know
if we can all we could all just bet
who's my i'm putting money on usman yeah
i'll put money on well as the resident
european i might have to go
you're going leon
super underdog okay why are you going
against the mandem
that's my dude but you know hometowns
demand
all right fair enough okay and then uh
that's the rock hole it looks like
costa's like a big favorite yeah yeah i
think that it's just about i think luke
is probably like a better martial artist
but if his chin doesn't hold up yeah and
holocaust is going to come straight at
him so if the chin doesn't hold up
yeah
yeah i mean if luke is smart he fights
paulo like izzy fought him which is just
leg kicks chew up that [ __ ] front leg
chew it up stay away and then once it's
chewed up and he can't move start
[ __ ] clobbering so there's money
there to be made there might be money
sports gambling guys
i've lost on bitcoin already i'm fine
i'm doing okay
pick up a little more gambling you know
what i mean gamble with your life go to
burning man yeah yeah yeah that's right
yeah parachute in all right i'm putting
money on the guy that's fighting costa
and i'm putting money on hoosman yeah
okay ooh
free money huh yo i got you man shots of
bet online bet on the line the
[ __ ] goats of this gamble and
[ __ ] what they're basically gonna do is
you bet up to a thousand dollars they're
gonna be matching it 50 okay you get a
free 500 up to 500
free to gamble with all you got to do is
use that promo code flagrant bet online
dot ag promo code flagrant get that free
money make even more money your
[ __ ] welcome free dollars if
you count the schultzy stimulus and the
sheldy stimulus obviously if you already
signed up after buying infamous you got
that fifteen dollars it's already in
your bank account for you go gamble so
go do that [ __ ] enjoy and watch our boy
camaro usman
make history again another title defense
yeah he's going he's going for mount
rushmore right now make it [ __ ]
happen